hey I'm Justin Trudeau and I'm so
excited to be here because I'm in
California with another lizard person
he's a lizard person just like me and
I'm here with him in California which
he's turned into a communist [ __ ]
just like I'm trying to do to Canada
we're both World economic Forum Stooges
but we have really nice
suits look at our suits and look at his
hair I just love him so much oh look at
him look at you I and I'm Gavin Newsom
look at me I smile when I'm talking so
people think I'm a nice guy but actually
I eat babies yes I do I love them
they're delicious and I'm always eating
them and then I use their blood as gel
in my hair it's very exciting for a guy
like me and I'm very happy to be here
with Justin Trudeau who is so evil that
makes me look like a good man yes isn't
it true Justin yes yes it is true yell
it you're just so cute I just love you
so much think about all of the people we
could lock in their homes and freeze
their bank accounts it's very exciting
for both of us I'm so happy about it
aren't you happy about it gab it's just
yeah oh yeah yeah love it